I am non chanda editor of Elle global
online and we are very pleased to have
with
senior studios professor Hillard
Huntington is the executive director of
energy modeling forum of Stanford
University and he has been an expert on
energy issues and has been currently
working on the energy and climate change
but this morning we want to talk to
Professor Huntington about the Iran
sanctions and the impact of Erin
sanctions on oil market and possibility
of a conflict with Iran that might
affect the world economy so progress the
Huntington welcome to yell thank you
very much pleased to be here so how the
steps to get an idea Iran is the third
largest supplier of oil and gas to the
world what actually is the volume what's
the quantity that there well they yes
yes the amount that they can they can
actually produce at least if we're going
with published data now for the most
part because we it's a little difficult
and sometimes because they because they
are going under sanctions and it's
difficult to tell for sure but about
three and a half million barrels per day
is is their their their production
capability they could be producing more
if they if they wanted to and that's
kind of the numbers that they're they're
they're talking about and so from what
you understand has the entire attorney
and export has been stopped or has are
distill exporting some quantity of the
there I think they're still exporting
some some quantities but it's been it's
been really shut down quite a quick
quite a bit by the sanctions the other
thing I should probably say that three
and a half million barrels per day
that's really the number i think of the
net amount that they have to export out
of the out of the out of their country
they also are users of oil and they
often are importing their gasoline if
they can and that's another constraint
put on the system by the sanctions it's
more difficult for them to use the so
they inform you
import gasoline yes they don't happy
enough refinery yeah yeah that's right
that's right that's right that's exactly
and so that is affected to their ability
yes that's being affected by the by the
sanctions as well so so the results
seems to have been a tremendous
inflation in Iran and and the collapsing
value of their currency dl that's right
there's been just a tremendous drop in
the value of the currency it's putting
incredible pressures on the on the on
the country at the moment I think we've
seen reports in the in the newspapers
and so forth about about how Ahmadinejad
is having pressures put on on him by the
people also by the the rulers in the in
the country so i think the it is putting
a fair amount of pressure on them so
this is one you can see for the west it
could be cutting once nose to spite
one's face how has it been the impact of
this depravation of Iranian oil on the
world economy yes well it turns out that
the Iranian oil supplies themselves I
think are not having a major impact the
removal of those spices not having a
major impact on the market and I think
one of the reasons is that there's the
availability of surplus capacity outside
of the Iran which which really offsets
that and a good example is like well the
energy information administration in
Washington runs an account of how much
excess capacity is available in the
market today and they and they're
suggesting something like maybe two and
a half million barrels per day out of
almost three and a half so so there's
the quite a quite a bit of capability
there and then there's also other
stockpiles that people can use as well
so so I don't think it's I mean it's
probably having some some effect on the
market but it's not a solid particularly
and it's but it's particularly Saudi
Arabia that's right that's what I should
have emphasized they have seen have been
producing right extra supplies they're
giving yeah the the production the
expansion of production in sorry
rabia has really increased a lot over
the last 12 months they've been very
aggressive but so the depolarizing the
gas price in the united states does it
have anything to do with the Iranian
sanction always has somewhere it's it's
it's it's it's it's a good deal
complicated some of it some of it is is
clearly due to that we also see quite a
even a bigger rise out in my part of the
world in the western part of the United
States because because we're also having
refinery problems and it turns out
refinery problems on the west coast has
has also been a been another big big
emphasis in the California market but
but but shorter term I mean there is
this of the Iranian situation has has
happened it basically the way to think
about it is this this curtailment or the
the Iranian supplies is the curtailment
of it is happening at a time when the
markets are are still relatively tight
yeah I mean there's there's still
economic growth particularly in Asia
it's starting to slow a little bit but
but that's what has really pushed up a
lot of the price price movement so there
are it's it's really important to
remember that this is a global market
and lots of things are happening in the
global market one of which is this
Iranian situation the fact that the
world economy in general in Europe
certainly and
and in Asia to Chinese to our beginning
to slow down them right and that slow
down reduces the demand for energy and
as a result doesn't let prices go up so
to some extent the impact of Iranian
sections have been offset by the low
growth that we are seeing today yeah
that's right and that's and that gets
back to this whole issue that you have
to look at it within a global global
perspective and you have to ask those
questions it's the same kind of thing
when we let me look at the US market we
say oh well this is happening but we're
only just part of the market and so you
have to look at it thanks globally yeah
so given the global nature of energy
supply and its impact index or worst
case scenario if there is a check on
Iranian nuclear research centers and
production centers and Iranian retaliate
by launching attack on Israel or other
countries and perhaps mind the Gulf to
prevent any Gulf oil from going out of
the area what kind of reaction or else
could we see in the world is it
something like the sewage crisis of 56
which led to some thirty two percent
rise in any year i think that i think
the percentage increased in a very bad
situation could could even be higher
than that i think what people are
particularly worried about is the the
Straits of Hormuz be it's a very shallow
body of water but there is an area where
you can get boats in and out but it's
it's a it's an excellent place if you
wanted to try to shut down production
and shut down the shipment of the of oil
you could do that now I don't think you
would imagine getting 17 it accounts for
about 17 million barrels
day of production of the so think of the
17 units of oil out of an oil market
which is almost in the high 80s the
total markings about high 80 so it's
about I think it's about about 20
percenters yeah yeah yeah yeah so so I
think that's the that's that's what
people are worried about you and that
would have a substantial impact on the
on the prawn the price of oil I I should
be quick to add that there are other way
if that should happen there are other
ways of getting oil out of the area
there there have been quite a bit of a
building of pipelines than oil pipelines
that will does it so it doesn't require
you go through the mos yeah and so
that's that's that's also could that be
from the switch canal or could it be
from the Ukrainian yeah yeah so yeah
it's a most suit canal Mediterranean as
well but they're they're operating on
both both both fronts but and I've seen
some pretty aggressive numbers there I
talked before about 17 million barrels
per day I've seen numbers in the
Financial Times saying it could be by
the end of the year it could be almost
six and a half million barrels per day
now whether I think logistically it
would be difficult to organize all that
but but there is that there is a game
six million barrels per day two we can
be shipped with it with a bypass went
through through these pipelines yeah
right so you that so that the net
disruption in the system would be
because against the percent yeah yeah
yeah okay but but also it depends also
at the state of the economy at the time
yeah yeah if the economy has turned
around and moving then it would be a joy
to the economy that's right that I try
and I try but in you have done so much
modeling and study of this impact what
would be the impact of a 7 million
barrel loss impact of that on the
on the on the on the gas spice in the
u.s. Forest well you have to kind of if
you're assuming that there are no
policies that are that are being put
into place the and and off times it's
difficult to put in policies in a time
of emergency and you assume that the
financial markets are pretty well there
no fine I mean it could be even worse
than what I'm saying because I'm about
to say because the financial market
could really just kind of just freeze up
but but you could get some substantial
you could get a kind of a one-time jolt
in the in the system which I think some
of my estimates in the very bat bat
worse situation could be maybe oil
prices more than doubling and the
economic I and the economy might be be
hit with a kind of five percent jolt in
the in it so and its well-being for
brief periods of time and then it would
would presumably come to come back but
but it's but it's very it but it's very
difficult to put but those numbers and I
actually spent more time looking at a
kind of a case where more just a part of
the disruption part of the the states of
whom was go out and and and that's a
kind of a more mild or impact with about
one percent of the impact one percent of
the gdp being being affected which is
still serious I mean it's still one
percent doesn't sound like a lot but
that's basically what we're spending in
for our military in in Iraq and
Afghanistan so it's a lot of gdp of u.s.
gdp yeah so so and also that's that
brings out that question up to do in
case of a conflict the the US military
would inevitably be involved you know
even if Israel initiate action us would
be involved and any any idea as to what
it could be the economic cost of that
kind of involvement now I
I'm probably not the best person to
really talk about that in the sense that
first of all I I notice that when people
talk about this estimate they have very
different concepts of costs that they're
putting in obviously you know some
people put in the cost of people being
being being killed in the war and or
taking care of the veterans afterwards
and things like this and and so I find
people to use different different cost
estimates of that so I don't have a good
answer yeah could we move to the other
area of your study is the question of
environment and climate change and
energy usage right now oil and gas
constitute perhaps the bulk of me
reduces today do you foresee alternative
energy use rising insignificant away in
the next 10-15 years yes I would put it
even maybe a longer-term strategy even
longer than that it before it to happen
I think there's going to be some some
dramatic changes that take place a part
of which is we're living through a world
of very high prices now and while we
really hate how high energy prices one
of the things high energy prices does is
it makes a lot of these other
alternative technologies very attractive
at least certainly more attractive than
that would be otherwise and so what's
what's happening in the innocent in the
situation is a lot of competition and I
think there are a lot of people
developing new renewable technologies
they're also developing a lot of
interesting ways of energy efficiency of
achieving energy efficiency which will
also have another another effect on the
on the on the system because the energy
West rejection has been almost twenty
percent or something of the world's
energy is wasted in me proper uses the
right yeah current the question is but
how much in energy efficiency Mia yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it's a energy efficiency and
in fact I'm really struck by how much
we've how much energy efficiency we've
seen just in our own country this going
back over the last three four decades
we've had an economy that up until the
financial collapse it was growing at
about almost six times as fast as their
as our energy use so we really made
significant dents in the in the amount
of energy being used and I think that's
really important the other thing that I
think is really interesting in this euro
high prices is that you you're starting
to see new types of oil and gas coming
on right now there's the big discussion
about shale oil and gas and that's been
had another big big impact but there is
some concern aboard the environmental
impact yeah of fracking on that point
what what is your view is well I I'm
it's an area i'm not an expert on but I
follow it closely because I want to know
and I look I look at the people at the
Department of Energy they've and they
have a panel that's a chaired by by
Professor Deutsche at MIT that's less
looked at this and one of my my
colleagues at Stanford mark so back is
serves on that panel and their view
seems to be that there are environmental
problems they need to be addressed but
that they can be addressed and that's
and so their view of that is that
they're manageable that they are
manageable and so that's more or less my
view of it I've looked at some of the
papers there's been a study at Cornell
that raised quite a bit of concern but
then there are other studies at places
like Carnegie Mellon which would seem to
say yes it's a problem but it's not a
it's not as big a problem as as people
were initially saying but I think what
it really tells you you really have to
you monitor this this the situation
carefully and and you want to continue
to be aware of what the possibilities
are there because you don't want to
unleash a new technology which is going
to create more problems
yeah there are some concerns about
creating a causing earthquake minor
earthquakes yeah yeah that's right
that's another issue that marks Lobeck
has talked to me a little bit about is
that there's quite a bit of work on the
other side and it does it does it
creates small amounts of earthquakes
there really now just trying to figure
out how serious those those those those
impacts are but but you know it drilling
in general often does does this kind of
stuff as well so I think we have to be
there's always what I've often tell my
students is that that any any energy
technology including solar and renewable
they all have risk involved in it and
you just have to dig it up risk yes
exactly a risk is very important yeah
the other final question is that is for
five years ago there's a lot of talk
about peak oil that that we are coming
to the end of the oil supply and even
share anymore what is your view is there
is this we are already seeing end of the
oil supply what'swhat's Europe yeah or
test well I think the the term Peak Oil
is unfortunate because it doesn't really
say why is it peeking and so forth but I
I think the notion but that they're
trying to get across the people who are
making this case is that the oil and the
gas that we're finding is more expensive
than the resources that we found
previously and I think this is more
expensive because we're a difficult to
yeah it's more difficult to elixir to
extract and and in even today people
have made this dramatic discoveries on
the shale gas and the shale oil in
particular and how the shale oil can
come in and and and maybe replace a lot
of the oil in the in the Middle East I
think you have to bring in the cost
element of it which is that this this
oil is available but it's more costly
than the oil in the Middle East and if
this if the Saudis are of a sudden see a
reduction in their and their supplies
they might decide to produce more of
that so so I mean I'm not as you know
the the issue of a peak oil is I think
they're that you're you're fighting
right you need to find more oil it's
more expensive than before but but I
don't think it's a kind of situation
that we're all of a sudden could be
running out of this stuff in the and but
also the new films have been found like
offshore brazil and there's now talk
about arctic exactly exact thing and and
i think that's that's good and I think
that's right these these sources are
coming on they're more expensive than
they then we've been getting before but
they are coming on and I think that's
the notion is it it's not it's not that
we're going to run out of this this
resource it's the fact that it's going
to be it's going to be more expensive
and we're already seeing prices today
that support these kinds of resources
being developed and so that's what's
going to happen so the energy
independence has been a slogan in the
United States for the past few years is
it being achieved is it we use the
internet chats close to achieving that
well you know it's interesting it
depends on how you want to define energy
independence my first job in Washington
was working on what they call project
independence which may be many of your
viewers don't remember but it was this
notion that when President Nixon was in
power that we were going to become
independent by a certain year and I
don't think people are really talking
about about that at least not seriously
I mean I think we still we are going to
reduce our imports it looks like if
certainly prices stay high and that's
that's probably a good thing but whether
we actually achieve this and abuts the
deadwood connection could be compensated
by shale oil and gas that's right yeah
that's what they're talking about there
would be the shale oil and gas and also
very important again I mentioned the
energy efficiency issue but but people
are moving to vehicles that are a lot
more energy efficient than before and
they're finding all kinds of ways to
reduce their energy use oh yeah yeah
well it was fascinating and thank you
for speaking to us well great i really
enjoyed it I've thank you my pleasure
was mine thank you thank you